all right here we go again n a has been
eliminated from the league of legends
world championships in the group stage
for the second year in a row
and i'm here to tell you once again why
it happened
how it happened and how to maybe fix it
which i'm not sure will even ever
happen at this point
all right so before we get into the
devastating failures of n a i want to
make sure that you all know to sub to
the channel and while you're doing that
make sure to like this video and leave a
comment
if you don't know what to leave a
comment about tell us what you want us
to see us make a video about whether
it's short story of don't
at me offbeat anything at all and if
you've got an idea that's a little too
long for the comments hit us up at tips
at the score.com so
it happened again na got eliminated from
worlds before the playoffs even started
they went a combined 6 and 12 in the
group stage which is a 33
win rate bumped up to a 40 if you factor
in play-ins
i'm gonna be real here though that is
not great for one of league's major
regions
uh it's heartbreaking man this time it
was kind of
the inverse of the enemy curse you know
we had a great week too it felt like tl
really ramped up
actually were able to to adapt and up
top before we get into the memes and
what happens next i want to make sure
that you all know that
this isn't all on the players you can't
just blame them and flame them on
twitter
because the problem as always is not the
players
it's the infrastructure for context here
the last time an na team made it out of
groups at worlds was c9 in 2018
and they made it all the way to the
semi-finals which was the furthest an a
team had ever gotten
but the last time a non-c9 team made out
of groups was tsm in 2014 when they and
c9 made it out together
basically na has a pretty bad track
record when it comes to worlds
they've done better at msi but for
whatever reason when you put them in a
wider field with more international
competition
they falter this year both flyquest and
team liquid went three and three so
there were some high points team liquid
went one and one with every single team
in their group including suning and g2
and flyquest handed top esports china's
number one seed their only loss of the
tournament so far
yeah i mean obviously it's kind of sad
that another ina team doesn't make it
out of three
three and three but what they took down
top
come on go watch them take down top like
that was
like uh kind of like a cherry on top on
that ice cream sundae on your flight
home to america
but
[Laughter]
i thought that flyquest really stuck to
their style right
and i was just you know i was proud of
this team even though yes they are
eliminated like all of the north
american lcs teams
even in their losses they looked good um
and they rallied
in their final days so you know black
western feel happy about how
at least you know the last day performed
it but tsm
na's number one seed well they got curb
stomped
tsm went 0 and 6 ingredients though to
be fair
they did have a pretty hard group this
is a fight tsm must find a way to win
whipple takes the first few shots
gonna lose some health here final shot
comes through for double puts in the
half
and this might fight is here yet again
can he make it happen
gotta get in there gonna be an ocean
soul claimed by fnatic and now it's time
for tsm to fight but is it going to be
enough they haven't gotten a single kill
yet
and already bjergsen goes down broken
blade to follow
it's three it's time for four and it's
time to fly home for tsm
spka runs his way as fast he can but
plane flights are faster
a triple kill for nemesis tsm
basically out of world look i'm not an
analyst or a coach
i can't tell you where players made bad
decisions or where drafts went wrong
what i can say is that smarter people
than me have said that n.a just got
outclassed at worlds here's mark z
talking about tsm's failed tower dive on
hotline league
how do we not kill him here how does csm
not just go and keep running forward and
chase down more kills
i literally cannot wrap my brain around
it this is the problem that
n a has more than anything else i think
is a total lack of like killer killer
instinct
even from our teams that are relatively
aggressive and and like this this is a
play
that every other region's top team if
they make this play will try to kill
everyone and and i that's just not how
any plays
and that's why we have low combined
kills per minute that's why these plays
go badly
gameplay aside though these issues are
symptomatic
of a greater issue in any league one
that's basically existed forever
there is a serious lack of homegrown
talent so
let's buckle in and really talk about
that for a second
na brought two players that we can call
rookies to worlds this year
spika and tactical everyone else is
someone you've already heard of
doublelift jensen bjergsen impact even
wild turtle made it to worlds this year
what n.a brought to worlds this year was
a bunch of players you've already heard
of before some strong imports who have
been taking it easy in n a for the last
couple of years and
two fresh faces and you might think well
they're rookies they're not supposed to
make it the worlds in their first year
and to be fair you'd be right but this
problem is true across
all of na's teams not just the ones who
want the world look at the rosters who
didn't qualify
it's all the same players you've already
heard of imports and
maybe one or two rookies to me it
doesn't seem like na is taking a risk by
playing these rookies that they've
signed their academy rosters on the lcs
stage
they're just signing the same 50 players
to their starting rosters over and over
again like it's the world's shittiest
game of musical chairs
now there are some teams out there that
are taking developing next generation
talent seriously hundred thieves for
example has a really built out system
with hundred thieves next and hundred
thieves academy 100 thieves next is
their amateur squad where they raise and
train young talents to make it to their
academy roster which
in turn can lead to players like whom
making it to the lcs all the way from
next
they're going in boom going in dusty's
called out flashes still dies
like we said earlier i i'm my bp's boom
amazing target play really really
impressed me and cloud9 has historically
done this work too
just last year they dumped their roster
for a bunch of rookies to motivate their
star players
and it's led to guys like blabber
becoming franchise talents
it's a long game but it's one that i
respect because a lot of
other teams in n a don't seem to be
keeping pace with it
so what happens when you don't have
young rookies filling in lcs slots
well you get a lack of innovation you
get stagnation
and look there are stories of things
like this happening before in spring
team liquid brought in tactical to help
motivate doublelift
and both tactical and doublelift are at
worlds now on different teams
clearly bringing in rookies can help and
if you're still not sure that an
increased focus on homegrown talent can
help a region succeed at worlds
take a look at china and korea's lineups
of worlds this year they are filled with
rookies they are not the same rosters
that you've seen at worlds year in and
year out
meanwhile rogue and madeline's both
feature plenty of rookies on their
rosters and
short neither of them did too hot but
the fact the matter is just making it to
worlds with such a young roster is
impressive in and of itself competition
is what breeds greatness
and right now penny doesn't seem very
competitive at least when it comes to
testing their franchise players by
putting them up against young rookies
hell it doesn't even have to be a
competition
older players can work with developing
talents on the same team and they can
both
improve now in theory academy exists
because riot wants to encourage teams to
develop new talent in that league
but it doesn't seem like that's what
every team is using it for some teams
are
signing former lcs players that you've
definitely heard of
zion spartan keith and matt all played
in academy this past year and they are
not the only ones this is a legitimate
question i have but
why if the purpose of these academy
teams develop new talent then
why are these spots not going to hungry
young players who still have plenty of
potential and the problems around
developing talent behind the scenes
might be worse than we think
recently lck caster and former coach ls
tweeted this
alleging that there are some players in
na who won't scrim with academy teams
because they're afraid that the academy
players on those teams are good enough
to take their jobs
if that's true and to be clear i have no
idea if it is
that's [ __ ] up because it means that
even the players don't care about
developing new talent
tyler ursberger who writes for espn
tweeted out this thought which is
something i'm sure a lot of na fans have
right now
he says the average salary for an lcs
player is 400
000 and this is how they perform at
worlds it's brutal
and once again it's a problem i'm sure
every single one of these orgs and
players want to win worlds
but it's unclear who is willing to do
the hard work that comes with getting
there
look there is a bit of a silver lining
here like i said earlier 100 thieves and
cloud9
are putting in the work and they're not
the only ones riot stepped in and
created scouting grounds a few years ago
to help get young talent in front of
teams
and look one or two scouting events a
year isn't going to magically turn
around na's international fortunes
but at least it's a step in the right
direction but these efforts can only do
so much
and c9 ceo jackie tien recently tweeted
that he thinks he
and the other teams aren't doing enough
so what does that say about na's focus
on developing new talent
like we mentioned earlier other regions
have figured this out to a certain
extent
europe has eu masters which has actually
been a pipeline to the lec
for many players in europe and has
allowed non-lec orgs to stay involved in
league
look it's been a weird year most of the
lcs season was played from players homes
and team houses
and international competition was swept
away by coven
so we never really got a real chance to
see how regions compared to each other
until worlds and without msi and worlds
and
regular international competition it's
hard for teams to improve that's fair
but let's be real here europe isn't
playing against china and korea every
weekend and
they have two teams in the quarterfinals
last year we did a video very similar to
this one and i ended it with this
statement
the fans are finally fed up the
conversation has reached a fever pitch
and if the players the coaches the staff
the management of the lcs
doesn't do something soon things are
looking pretty dark for the future of
any league of legends
and guess what things continue to be
dark but the ball
is still in a's court these orgs want to
make it out of groups the players want
to win worlds
the fans just want something to believe
in again i genuinely believe that
it's all possible it's just gonna take
some hard work
okay we are recording before you got
here we were having some lab issues i
solved them i'm a [ __ ] computer
genius
i unplugged the cable in the receiver
and plugged it back in
wow the technical expertise
blown away give me the nobel prize
here's my question so they did the
dragon and then they did kda
what giant ar like [ __ ] show are we
getting this year
i mean i say [ __ ] show it was cool what
big ar thing are we getting this year
i would like a big 80 800 foot tall
galio personally
i have a brand i have to commit to it i
saw galio got some play at worlds that
got me excited
so one of the games i was watching had a
galio in it i can't remember which game
it was but
there was indeed a galio